[Music]  here's how it works this is where we  take video of famous people and we  combine them usually for no good reason  first up we've melded Bill Clinton and  Nancy Grace I think the same thing will  happen in soon I think you will see the  gravitational forces of American  politics pushing us toward louis c.k and  lindsey Lowen so that's really more  about anything they say we're [ __ ]  generation and I meant to say that we're  shitty generation Newt Gingrich and  Callista Gingrich from our family  I'm toaster Gingrich and I'm Newt  Gingrich and I approve this and finally  Steve Buscemi and Reese Witherspoon it's  one of those nights you know the way out  to dinner in Atlanta and we had one too  many glasses of wine we've got real time  to drive and we absolutely were not  acceptable  he's still beautiful